so you remember the old show with Regis
Philbin
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire you
remember this show it was crazy
something else there was a whole life
Steve Martin had a great bit and his
comedy bits many years ago how to be a
millionaire well first you get a million
dollars you remember with the first of
the year when we sat down you and I and
I walked through okay if you're going to
have goals not wishes not dreams but
goals goals have to be five things they
have to be specific they have to be
measurable they have to have a time
frame they have to be written down then
they have to be your goals my wife wants
me to lose weight
we'll never cause you to lose weight my
mother want to always wanted me to be a
dentist you'll be a lousy dentist you
know you need to own the goal so here's
the thing let's just say that your goal
was financial stability inland financial
wealth not because you wanted to be a
greedy jerk but because you just wanted
to stabilize your life you want to
retire with dignity change your family
tree not be in financial stress so your
goal is to have some money let's call
that money a million dollars I want to
be a millionaire a millionaire is
someone whose assets - their liabilities
equals a million dollars so we're in the
process here of finishing up and putting
the final touches on the largest and
most comprehensive study of millionaires
ever done in the United States we will
have just under 10,000 of them that will
have given us detailed in-depth
information by the time we're through I
don't want to blow the surprise but
there aren't any surprises you know how
you become a millionaire you set out to
become a millionaire it's a goal and it
can't be someone else's goal
has to be your goal you have to be
willing to do what it takes now once you
say okay I'm willing to do what it takes
what do you do what do you do how do you
do it
well one of the big things we find is is
that they millionaires the the vast
majority of them the primary way they
became millionaires was investing in
their 401 K work in good growth stock
mutual funds over about a 20-year period
of time and the vast majority of them
invest around fifteen percent of their
household income what we teach you at
baby step four so it turns out baby step
four is genius
we knew this we knew this we've been
doing this for 25 years but we've got
the data points to prove it everyone
gets all upset about what the rate of
return is on your 401 K but the primary
driver of retirement success according
to a study done by the AAAS
PPA the actuaries consultants
administrators and other retirement plan
professionals a group of nerds
you know what the primary driver of
retirement success is according to them
savings rate which means how much you
put in not what you make on it not what
the expense ratios or commissions are
but what you actually put in now the
vast majority of people who put in
fifteen percent of their income are very
careful to select a good strong mutual
funds to put it in so they do get a
great rate of return for instance last
year the martin stock market SP was
19.4% up so you had a good year last
year if you were investing that's the
process so you invest it in decent
mutual funds but most importantly 74% of
it has to do with whether or not you
actually invest are you going to invest
so a a lot of the large companies have
now started with something I don't agree
with but it doesn't matter whether I
agree with it they're gonna do it anyway
automatic registration for your 401 K
this report just came out from the Dow
Jones News Corp the downside of
automatic 401k savings equals more debt
so here's what's happening okay I'll
read a little bit of article
automatic enrollment into your 401k when
you take a new job that automatically
put you in the 401k is fast becoming the
default method of getting new employees
into u.s. retirement plans since the
Treasury Department began in acting rigs
to support the use of auto enrollment in
the late nineteen ninety 68% of large
employers have adopted it by the way
almost no small employers have adopted
that's odd but the large companies seem
to have this in any state mentality some
of them a lot of them 68% of large
employers have adopted it up from 58% in
2015 and only 34% of them that auto
enrolment in 2007 so it's it's becoming
quite the fad to auto enroll what's
wrong with that Dave I don't know
because that's someone else's goal it's
not your goal unless you have a goal to
be a millionaire and you emotionally own
the goal and you are going to be
intentional and say what must be true in
my life for me to hit that goal no one
can automatically make you become a
millionaire because you know here's what
happens they auto and roll these people
into their 401k so 85% of eligible
employees participate remaining 15% drop
out compared with 66 percent who
actually engage in the plan if you have
to sign up to do your 401k be
intentional about joining it employees
who were Auto to enrolled amassed an
average of thirty two hundred and thirty
seven dollars during four years so
that's about eight hundred bucks a year
in their 401k contributions and more
than those who were left to sign up on
their own thing at thirty two hundred
dollars more on average but the
auto-enrolled employees also had an
average of fifteen hundred sixty three
dollars more in consumer debt and four
thousand one hundred thirty one dollars
more in mortgage debt so they took on
about six thousand dollars worth of debt
and which by the way those are two
indicators you won't become a
millionaire you stay in mortgage debt
and you stay in consumer debt and thirty
two hundred dollars worth Assoc
six thousand dollars in the hole three
thousand dollars up net loss of $3,000
for auto enrollment so the big question
says John Friedman an economist at Brown
University this is how you get the big
bucks right here you're an economist at
Brown University a big question is
whether auto enrolment makes you save
more overall and my reading of this
paper is that no it doesn't thank you
John
you might you you my friend have a firm
grasp on the obvious you do what I do
you take things that are very obvious
and state them that's what I do - I'm
Dave has a firm grasp on the obvious one
of my college professors told me that
one time but John has that too the
economists at Brown University because
if you go $6,000 in debt on average
while you save $3,000 more than the
average person $6,000 more in debt than
the average person then your $3,000 in
the hole over there which person you'd
have been better off to be the average
person how about we choose none of the
above how about we choose you decide to
have an intentional goal you decide to
tell your money what to do you decide to
join your 401k you decide to invest on
purpose 15% of your income after you've
gotten yourself out of debt and on a
budget the way we teach on baby step
four and you will be on track to in
about 20 years become a millionaire some
of you sooner
it has to be your goals your company
can't do it for you your companies that
are trying to be the nanny state for
these people know what you need to do is
motivate them not do it for them you
cannot do stuff for people who don't
care